so
you know with scale bound
I had to sit for a little bit and then
because it came from two sources I was
like so am I okay to go with this
and they're like
okay go for it but make it clear make it
clear that this is probably a long way
away okay like this is this is early
days which is why I said at the time I
don't know if they're gonna restart I
don't know if they're going to pick up
the pieces of what scalebound was in
when did they cancel it
2017 2018 something like that sounds
about right it sounds about right that
window I don't know if they're gonna
pick up the pieces of that I don't know
if they're gonna start again so it's
something that's probably a Fair Way
awake okay okay
um what I mean other people have pointed
it out Platinum themselves publicly said
publicly outside your defense thought
they out here they're asking asking